y estamos sacando adelante de la suprema
corte de brasil
y delante de una pantalla instalada para
que 1.500 indígenas de los 6000 estaban
la semana pasada puedan acceder a lo que
es la causa de los choques está siendo
juzgada acá dentro de la suprema corte
por ahora habla un miembro de la
sociedad civil y del gobierno son 39
todavía faltan los votos de los 10
ministros de la suprema corte de brasil
la causa daría seguridad jurídica a la
demarcación de tierras de centenares de
pueblos originarios de brasil
por eso la expectativa de la casa es la
causa es de los chilenos indígenas de su
de brasil pero la jurisprudencia
serviría todos todo un pueblo marcado
por conflictos de tierras minería si el
avance del agronegocio por eso se quedan
acá todo lo que pueden con la
expectativa de esta noche dormir es
sabiendo que mañana son legalmente son
los dueños de sus tierras